this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
your nasal septum is a thin wall that
divides the inside of your nose into
right and left sides
it's made of soft flexible cartilage in
the front
and bone in the back
a thin layer of tissue called the nasal
mucosa covers the septum
if you have a deviated septum your
septum is bent instead of straight
a deviated septum can block airflow
through your nose
the procedure to fix problems with your
nasal septum is called a nasal
septoplasty
to begin the procedure the surgeon will
make an incision in the mucosa inside
one of your nostrils
then the mucosa will be lifted away from
the septum so the surgeon can see it
to straighten the septum the surgeon may
make a few cuts in the cartilage to
relax it
sometimes the bent part of the septum
may need to be removed
your surgeon will leave behind enough
cartilage to support your nose
after the procedure the incision will be
closed with stitches
in some cases where your septum isn't
removed more stitches will be passed
through your septum to keep it straight
your surgeon may put splints in your
nose to support the septum while it
heals
the splints will be removed after a few
days
if you want to find out more about nasal
septoplasty talk to your healthcare
provider
you